hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga and we are currently in the match
against adolf andersen the german master
and
the first game morphy lost he lost by
playing the evans gambit and it's one of
the few
evidence gambit games that morphe lost
in his entire short career
and this is now the second game it's
really an enjoyable one and features a
lot of cool moments but before we check
out the game uh something i forgot to
mention in the previous video
uh the result of the great tournament in
london of 1851 that
adolf anderson attended i just wanted to
show you something so
uh here are the results as you can see
out of anderson won the tournament okay
uh here he doesn't say so but uh in the
finals you can see that he defeated
marmaduke with a
with a score of 42 but in the
semi-finals who
did adolf anderson uh defeat yes it is
it is our good friend howard stoneton
uh and he defeated him by a result of
four to one
uh to reach the final so just something
i wanted to mention and this was
uh back in 1851 so some
uh seven years before before this match
here with morphe so even then
uh you you can see that uh okay maybe
stanton had a bad day but
uh even in his more you know
younger days he wasn't uh
always that strong as he wanted everyone
to believe
uh but he did have his moments and maybe
maybe one day we can make like a short
howard staunton day just to check if you
know if that guy could play chess or not
because we've never seen a game
i mean i have but i haven't shown any on
this channel but getting back to this
game this is the second game of the
greatest
match of that era out of anderson versus
paul charles morphe let's see what
happened it's uh
well it's it's it's a great one so now
anderson with the white pieces
opens with e4 morphe replies with e5 we
have knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 going for
the royal opus
and morphy of course goes for a6 the
morphe defense or morphy's defense
uh we have bishop to a4 and now knight
to f3 and here we have d3 the so-called
anderson variation
of this line of the rule opus so
basically by reaching almost the end of
the morphe saga we've
we've kind of uh you know reached the
the beginnings of chess
under some variation versus the the
morphe defense uh we have bishop the c5
and now
c3 and this is something that it's still
uh being played today
if you you know uh follow what's
happening in the world you can see
variations like these uh being played
everywhere
uh in the this year i it was in uh
february or or march uh
levon had this position against magnus
cross and magnus carlos and won the game
very nicely was in the magnus cross and
the invitational
uh magnus went with the d6 here but here
we have b5 by morphe
challenging the bishop here uh and now
bishop back to c2 and now again
uh this position has been reached many
times uh more
notable games include uh such as anand
versus
wesley so uh from the 2018 grand chester
in luven
uh where d6 was played but here morphy
strikes more aggressively in the center
with the d5
we have e captures on d5 knight captures
on d5
and now h3 uh just preventing this dark
square bishop from being developed
we have castles by both sides morphe
castles anderson castles and
now d4 uh sorry uh first h6 by morphe
preventing this
bishop from being developed to g5 and
only now d4 by anderson attacking
morphy's bishop with e captures on b for
c captures and now bishop back to b6 and
now
uh knight to c3 developing with while
attacking this knight on d5 we have
knight
d to b4 uh now kind of trying to get uh
white to play a3 here but the bishop is
attacked so of course
anderson wants to save his light square
bishop his bishop pair is very nicely
placed here
and now morphy would also enjoy placing
his bishop
pair on such nice diagonals but if you
go bishop to b7 a3 is just too strong
for white for example knight to d5
uh and now we're just gonna capture it
uh knight captures queen captures and
now queen to d3 already i
understand it's threatening checkmate
then you you have to weaken your
uh position with a move like g6 so maybe
uh not as enjoyable then bishop to a2 is
coming you know put
putting the bishop on this diagonal then
queen to g6 becomes a threat so
not and something black doesn't really
need to worry about uh
if he plays correctly so morphe plays
bishop to a6 this is the the more
correct idea and now after a3 and knight
to d5
anderson doesn't really gain anything by
exchanging here because if you exchange
then
uh morphy's light square bishop becomes
a monster so after knight to d5 we have
knight to e2
shifting the knight over to the king
side for the attack we have knight to f6
by morphy
and now bishop to e3 uh we broke the e8
by morphy and now
knight to g3 by anderson uh knight's f4
seems to be a more active move and you
know attacks the bishop you know
controls a lot more squares but uh
anderson has a very cool idea
and he plays knight to g3 uh we have
bishop to c4 by morphy attacking the
rook here on f1
uh and now anderson could just play
bishop to d3 we could trade a light
square bishops and you know
nothing special about this game but
anderson is not that kind of a player
and he did not earn such a name for
himself in chess history
by playing moves like bishop to d3 so
here anderson plays
knight to f5 he says go ahead and
capture my rook
and it's uh it's um uh you know
uh hard capture to decline because it is
the best move so
yeah it's not a correct sacrifice but
anderson makes it correct
so morphe goes for the rook bishop
captures on f1 we have queen captures
and now
knight the e7 challenging anderson's
knight on f5 but now
knight 3 to h4 improving his position
and now if this knight captures this
knight takes its place but it's not a
problem
since uh morphy wants to get rid of as
many attackers as possible so knight
captures on f5
knight captures on f5 and now queen to
d7
developing the queen preparing to bring
the other rook into the game
but now anderson says uh nope this is
only the beginning of my attack in place
bishop captures on h6 so we reach the
position from the thumbnail
uh i imagine if this will be the
thumbnail and morphe now
has to make a choice does he capture the
bishop or not i mean
it'd be silly not to capture it
[Music]
if you don't capture it you're just
saying okay you do whatever you want i'm
just going to roll over and you know
do your thing so here murphy of course
captures the bishop and
now not capturing with czech but rather
queen to c1
going for queen captures on h6 and queen
to g7 checkmate so this is anderson's
actual idea uh but uh the
uh finding the the correct path to
defending this position is not an easy
one so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the correct way to
defend this for morphe while i give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
realizing that morphy should not be
defending this position morphy should
actually be attacking i was only
tricking you
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop captures on
d4
uh seems like an obvious move to play
but you have to see
a few moves further to realize why this
is so strong
uh underscore understand of course
played queen captures on h6 now
threatening checkmate
and now morphy plays rook to e1 with
check we have king the h2 and now there
is one more move that is much needed
to you know not only defend but to also
counter attack uh so feel free to pause
the video for the second time and
win this game for morphe while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
realizing that rook captures rook queen
captures knight and all of the good
stuff so you know
you know what to do and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen captures on f5 that's the move
morphe had to play in order to win the
game
but he did not play it uh for some
reason
for example bishop captures rook
captures and now black's
black is simply to too far up in
material
okay white has a queen but it's two
rooks a bishop and the knight i mean
that's uh that that is winning for black
if queen g5 check we can just move the
king if queen h6 check
we simply move the king to a7 then we
bring the rook into the game we
hide the king okay not there somehow to
the queen's uh to the queen side
uh okay not through this but somehow
then maybe double rooks here and you
know
black would definitely figure it out but
morphe for some reason didn't play this
instead morphe played knight to e4 which
kind of works nicely but
uh only if anderson makes a mistake okay
now the bishop is defending the g7
square
so there is no checkmate and if you go
for
for example for bishop captures uh uh no
not for bishop captures on e4 this was
played in the game but
uh if you go for knight captures to
eliminate this uh well
bishop uh then okay queen captures on d4
and now if bishop captures an e4 we can
just play rook captures on e4
uh it's not a problem we're not going to
go after the rook and here black would
be completely winning
however after knight to e4 we have
bishop captures on e4 by anderson
and now comes rook captures on e4
you can't go for rook captures on um
on a1 because then knight captures on b4
and if queen captures on d4 you're
getting checkmated bishop to h7 check
runs into a well very very well known
checkmating uh
pattern queen h7 checking if a queen
captures on f7 and black gets checkmated
so instead after bishop captures an e4
we have rook captures on e4
and now queen to g5 with check we have
king to f8
queen to h6 check and now morphy doesn't
want to repeat
morphe brings the king over to the
center of the board uh he
he wants to win this game so knight
captures on d4
and now again what do you play here the
problem is
you can't capture with the rook and you
can't capture with the queen
if you capture with the rook then rook
to e1 check and it's game over
let's say king to d8 queen to f8 check
and only one square for the queen
queen to e8 and this is now checkmate
and if you don't uh capture with the
rook
uh after this knight captures on d4 you
could capture with the queen but then
you
lose control over the c6 square if queen
captures on d4
queen to c6 check uh anderson wins back
his rook
and then it's uh it's just a draw so and
you know black's king is much more wide
in the open so
if anything white would white would be
better here so instead after knight
captures on the f4 morph he says all
right
i can capture with the rook i can't
capture with the queen i have to go for
queen to d6
check and get the queens off the board
so anderson
traits here we have uh queen captures on
d6 c captures on d6 and
now rook to d1 and now we have two rooks
for morphe
uh against a knight and rook for
anderson but anderson is up upon and
those
three pawns on the king side could be
could be troublesome so let's see
how these gentlemen played this end game
so king to f8
we have rook to d2 now the knight can
move and the rook will not have access
to the second
second rank we have rook eight to e8
morphe doubles up on the e file
and now g4 anderson is ready to start
bringing the king into the game and
pushing those king side pawns we have
rooked
rook 8 to e5 and now controlling a lot
of squares here those two rooks are just
monsters
and f3 now attacking the rook here
uh rook to e1 and now h4 those pawns are
now
going to be pushed forward we have rook
to d5 with this rook to d5 move morphy
makes sure that
this knight cannot move because then we
just trade rooks and then we are winning
and the rook cannot move because then
the knight falls
uh and not much uh to be done about
white's position so here instead we have
king to g3
anderson improves the position of his
king and now a5 by morphe with h5
and now king the g8 by morphe king 2f2
attacks the rook we have
rook back to e8 by morphe king to g3
now king to h7 we have king to f4 and
now
rook to e7 and rook to e7 uh is
maybe not the most ambitious way to play
this say if you really
let the engine crunch this position you
will get uh some sort of a crazy line
like
a4 uh and then after white makes a move
white can only wait for black to do
do something active so let's a king g3
now b4
and now white will again ignore this
he's going to play king f2 or king f4
we're going to play
f5 now and now after g captures on f5
now we're going to play b
captures on a3 a cap b captures on a3
and now rook back to e5 and now we are
threatening rook captures here
because this rook is undefended and if
rook to d1 or something the king cannot
cross the the
the e file uh and if we play something
like this
rook captures on f5 if king to e3 then
we
repeat rook f to e5 king to d3 now rook
captures on h5
and you get some sort of a position like
this where black has
excellent winning chances but try
harding in chess was not invented until
bobby fisher started playing
uh so after king to f4 we have rooked
the e7 by morphe
and now king to g3 we have f6 by morphe
king to f4
rook to e8 and now king to g3 we have
rook to e7
and he was in this position on 44 that
uh alpha anderson and paul charles
morphe drew their game
as there is seemingly nothing more to be
done here and objectively now the
position is a draw
uh uh you know could be but also you
know in in those days and i guess
anything could happen but uh
it seems it was the the genuinely thing
to do to to agree to a draw here
uh so yeah very well played by anderson
uh he now uh defeated morphy in the
first game
uh drew morphy in the second game and
we'll see what happens uh in the other
games as
we've said it before it's first the
seven wins
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank defending family
uh greg fanning kevin fanning mark
fanning terry fanning everett becky
fanning turner for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it finishes
uh thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day